ん
[音楽]
me
こんにちは
去年1月私たちのジャパン方ブラック
lives にいつの動画が送られてき
ました
その動画は東京駅の構内で職務質問を受け
ているまさにその瞬間のものでした
メッセージにはこう書かれていました
今日の職務質問されたのですが今回は一番
やな経験でした
もしよかったらこの動画を使ってください
日本の偏見がなくなる社会の貢献に役立ち
ますよ
動画を開いてまずびっくりしたのが職務
質問を受けているのは私の友人の息子さん
だったんです
彼もこのアカウントを運営していたのが私
だと知らずにただこの動画を共有して職務
質問の現状を広めたいという思いで送って
きてくれたみたいなんです
動画の内容はこんな感じでした
夕方の時間帯の東京駅の構内で2人の警察
官が所持品の検査と身分証の提示を求めて
いました
それに対して彼は何で自分のターゲット
入植の質問したんですかと聞いていました
検察はこう答えたんです
ドレッドヘアが悪いわけではないですけど
まあドレッドヘアでおしゃれな方も結構
薬物を持っていることが私の経験上今まで
多かっ
この警察とのやりとりは約25分くらい
続いてたんですが私はこの一言が未だに
消化できないでいます
その時間帯だけでも数万人が駅巻駅の構内
で警察官が彼一人にターゲットを絞った
理由がレッドヘアでオシャレだから
これが職務質問を正当な理由になるのかな
私は思いました
彼は駅構内にいた他の多くの人と違う外見
的特徴を持っていました
一つ目は警察官がドレッドといったその
ヘアスタイル
ん
これはロック生あーと呼ばれるんですが
このロックスラーはアフリカ系の方々の
ナチュラルヘアにとてもマッチしたや白湯
で古くから受け継がれてきた大切な文化で
もありますつまり彼らのアイデンティティ
ともいえるものなんです
二つ目は彼がばらまく日本ルーツを持つ
ミックスレース日本では u ハーフと
呼ばれるかためやんということです
それ以外はごくごく普通の帰宅途中の成人
男性です
そう考えると警察官が彼に声をかけた理由
は彼がロック西安の外国人風の見た目で
そこにいたほか納税の一つに比べて目立っ
ていたからなんだろうなって思います
その数ヵ月後にまた1本別の動画が送られ
てきました
その動画は千葉県でナイジェリアと日本の
ミックスルーツの20代の男性が日中に
歩いていたところを職務質問されていると
いう動画でした
で彼もまたロックス部屋でしたいっ
彼は職務質問されたことに納得がいか
なかったので警察官に見た目で声をかけた
んですか聞いたんです
塩返ってきた言葉がこうでした
検察官が見た目で声をかけちゃいけないん
ですか
まあ例えば明らかに見た目の様子が
おかしいとかをふらつきながら歩いてい
たり
まあ例えば服に血がついていたりとかまた
は通行人に絡んでいたりあるいは警察官を
見てくるっと引き返したりとかそんな様子
だったら明らかに不審なので声をかけるの
はまあ当然だと思います
それに私自身は職務質問そのものに関して
は街の安全を維持するための大切な業務だ
とも思っています
ですが見た目で声をかけたと言ってしまっ
ているのでその見た目っていうのは
やっぱり肌のいる部屋したいということに
なってしまうと思います
そのミックスの男性は日本で生まれ育って
今会社員をしていてお子さんのいる父親で
もあるんですね
で歩いていた場所彼の地元なんです
肌の色や黒人の方特有の髪質や髪型って
いうのは生まれもったナチュラルな外見的
特徴なので
たとえその場で他の人と違って目立ってい
たとしてもこれを利用に職務質問するのは
正直偏見じゃないかなっていうふうに私は
思います
偏見というのは特定の集団に対してイラク
偏った見方だったりその偏った見方を
ベースにして個人をジャックすることです
その偏見は多くの人に浸透している固定
関連や清涼タイプからくるものです
例えば
メディアの影響で黒人は犯罪者が多いとか
ドレッドヘアはあまり反応のイメージとか
そういったネガティブな資料タイプがある
じゃないですか
このようなネガティブな車両タイプは社会
的して熊というものを生み出してしまい
ます
この社会的してるなっていうのは差別や
偏見の対象として扱われる属性のことだっ
たりそれ自体が持つのイメージのことです
ステレオタイプで物事を見てしまうとその
特徴を持つ集団に属するというだけでこの
人もどうせそうなんだろうっていうような
目で見られてしまいますつまりその特徴を
持つ集団に属するというだけで社会的して
雲のせをされてしまうという事ですか簡単
に言えば
とばっちりで嫌な目に遭ってしまうという
事ですよねます
山皆さん
米シャルプロファイリングという言葉が
あります
これは警察がコイン
肌の色や民族あるいは国籍言語またはそう
ですね宗教などの属性を理由に捜査の対象
とすることを言います私はこの2件の職務
質問について
フェイシャルプロファイリング疑われると
言ってもいいんじゃないかなと思う
ところで
アメリカでは人種差別が法律で違法とされ
ていますですが現実は黒人の方をはじめと
した有色人種に対する米シャル
プロファイリングが方向をしていてとても
大きな問題になっています
一方日本では
人差別を剣士する法律すら実はないんです
よね
なのでレイシャルプロファイリングに
対する認識も警察だけじゃなく日本全体と
して正直まだまだ低いんじゃないかなと
思います
この2つの職務質問の動画を私たちの
ソーシャルメディアに投稿したんですが
本当に様々な反応が返ってきました
その中でこの場を借りていくつか並進し
たいものがあるのでご紹介します
一つ目
警察は肌のように言及してないから差別
じゃなくない被害妄想でしょう
そうですね確かに肌の色には言及して
なかったですですが6世あの人に声を
掛ければ結果的にアフリカにルーツがある
人の割合は高くなってしまいますそれに
ロックスヘアの形だけじゃなくてまあ坊主
のようなショートヘアの黒人の方々も何度
も職務質問をされたという話は私たちの
もと多く寄せられています
そしてこの被害妄想だって言う言葉ですが
この問題に限らず人権問題ではよく頭うち
者じゃない方々から聞こえてくる言葉なん
ですよ
実際に彼らは受けなくてもいいはずの負担
を課されていますよね
これは妄想ではないんです
職務質問を受けたことがない人の方が
日本では大多数なのでみんなが被害妄想だ
と言ってしまうと
そちらの声のほうが大きくなってしまうの
でマイノリティの方の勇気のは訴えを
抑え込んでしまうことになってしまいます
次2つ目
やましいことがないなら警察の手を煩わせ
ず職務質問に協力すればいいじゃん
所持品を見せても何も困るものを出てこな
いっていうのは本人が一番分かっているの
で確かに早くこの場を収束させるっていう
点においては職務質問に応じたほうが賢明
かもしれないですですが偏見で声をかけ
られて不利益を被ったことこれに対しては
ちゃんと抗議すべきだと私は思うんです
じゃないとこれから先もずっと一部の人
たちだけ理不尽なことに我慢をし続け
なきゃいけなくなりますよね
またミックスの人たちなどははじめ外国人
だと思われて警察に声をかけられることが
多くてそのたびに在留カードの提示を求め
られたりします少しだけ想像してみ
ましょう
自分が生まれ育った国で在留カードにして
くださいとかどこから来たの日本語される
こんな経験が何度も何度も積み重なって
いくとまるで自分が日本人として認めて
もらってないような気分にさせられて自尊
心も傷つけられてしまいます
3つ目
ドレッドヘアを止めればいいんじゃない
ですか
そうですね例えば私の学校まっすぐな髪質
の日本人がファッションの一部として本来
のこの髪質を変えてまでロックス部屋を
作り込んだり
または x でで装着したりするのは他社
の文化をファッションとしてまということ
を自分自身が選択しているのでまあそれは
やめるのも簡単だと思います
ですがそもそもロックスヘアは先ほどお
話ししたように彼らのナチュラルヘアから
来ているものですし自分自身のルーツや
アイデンティティーを示す文化的民族的な
大切なものなので
まーたしたからそのように言われる必要が
果たしてあるのかなとは思いますし
そもそも特定の髪型だけピックアップさ
れることが問題だと思います
日本で日本人としていわゆる大多数の日本
人の見た目で生活していると生まれながら
に自分たちがいろんな場面で優遇されて
いることに無自覚になってしまいます
例えば
スマホや賃貸の契約だったり自治体で
サービスを受けるときなんかに書類を書い
て提出するような作業でも私たちはめんど
くさいなぁと思いながらも当たり前に
こなしますですが日本語の書類を読むだけ
でも大変な方もいますし
物件の契約を理由もなく断られたりお店の
入り口に外国人お断りという張り紙がある
西嫌な思いをする方もたくさんいます
でも大多数の日本人はそういう不遇な状況
があることにすら気づかないで暮らすこと
ができていいます
これは特権と呼ぶんですがこの特権がはの
グループのことをマジョリティと言います
マジョリティが自分の持つ特恵に無自覚な
まま
マイノリティの不利益に目を向けず3
あるいは共感しようとせずに来ガールの彼
らだと主張したり被害妄想だって決めつけ
たりまたは権力のある元視点からだけ物事
を見ていてもこの問題を冷静に考えること
はちょっと難しいんじゃないかなという
ふうに思います
なので私はまず話を聞いて精いっぱい当事
者の気持ちを想像しようと努めます
100%理解できると思いませんが少なく
とも自分の特権を自覚した上で次の
アクションを考えるようにしています
じゃあ次に職務質問を受けた人たちには
どんな負担があるのかに注目してみます
時間を失う
ご存知の方も多いと思いますが職務質問は
任意ですですが警察も成果を上げないと
いけないので応じるまではなかなか帰して
もらえないことが多いです
なので大切な用事があって急いで行っても
職務質問でその時間を奪われてしまいます
自尊心やプライドを傷つけられる
公共の場で質問されるので多くの人の目に
さらされますし食品もそのまで全部見られ
てしまいます
パブリックな場である種のハラスメントを
受ける心理的負担っていうのは非常に
大きいと思います
信用を失っ
職務質問を受けている最中にもしかしたら
あなたの友人や職場の同僚あるいは取引先
の人に見られる可能性だってあります
ネガティブなイメージを持たれて信用を
失ってしまうかもしれません
ステレオタイプの所長
検察に止められている人を見たらこの人
何かしたのかなで反射的に思う人は少なく
ないと思います
ここで外見的な特徴があった場合それが
そのまま術をタイプの助長に繋がって
しまいますね
精神的肉体的負担
私の友人は職務質問を受けた後はとにかく
一日中ずっと気持ちの長女どころがないと
おっしゃってました
その後何年経っても思い出すために当時の
記憶がよみがえってストレスを感じたり
するそうです
ある人は職務質問を何回かされた結果元札
を見ると反射的にこう体がこわばるように
なってしまって
今回こそ声をかけられないようにド緊張し
ながら通り過ぎようとしたところをその
動作が怪しいという理由でまた尺間質問を
されてしまいました
警察官職の思考法という法律があります
68年間改定が行われていない村です
警察官は異常な cad その他周囲の
事情から合理的に判断して何らかの犯罪
犯しのしか犯そうとしていると疑うに
足りる相当な理由のある者
または既に行われた犯罪についてい
もしくは犯罪が行われようとしていること
について知っていると認められるものも
停止させて質問することができる
職務質問された私の友人に異常な挙動や
犯罪を犯そうとしていると疑うに足りる
相当な理由
これは言うまでもなくありませんでした
3私たちには現状を変えるためにどんな
ことができると思いますか
先ず一つね実態を多くの人に知ってもらう
こと
今日お話しした3型の仕組み質問彼らが
焼香残すべきだと自分たちで判断して自ら
こう撮影をしていました
のし今後私たちが不当な可能性のある職務
質問の現場に遭遇することがあれば撮影
録音または日本語の通訳などを申し出る
ことはまあ一つのせいだと思います
二つ目
当事者の話に耳を傾けること
もし皆さんがマジョリティな
もし皆さんが職務質問を受けたことがない
なら
当事者が受ける負担を深く理解することは
難しいかも知れませんですが彼らの気持ち
に寄り添って共感しようとすることが可能
です
まずは自分の特権に築くところから始め
ましょう
違いはその特権だけでその特許の取り除い
たらみんな同じただの人間であるという
ことをいつも忘れないようにしたいですよ
ね
3つ目声を大きくする
当事者じゃないから声をあげていいのか
わからないとか
サポートしたいけどもし間違ったことを
言って突っ込まれたら怖いという人が
たくさんいますその気持ちはすごくわかり
ます私自身もそうでしたですが発言力や
決定権のある政治家やメディアに注目され
ている人たちあるいは他音や人脈がある人
こういう人たちはみんなマジョリティー
です私たちも日本に生まれただけで
マジョリティと呼ばれます
なのでマジョリティ側の人たちこそ
マイノリティの声を拾い上げて広めるべき
なんですそうすることでこれは私たち
みんなが課題として取り組むべきことで
あるという認識が広がりますし変えること
もできますなのでその特権はどんどん使っ
ていきましょう
もちろん間違いは誰になってあるのでその
都度学んでいけばいいと思います
他社の間違いにも寛容になりましょう
日本でも多様化が進んでますし人権意識や
ねんり感は昔に比べると向上しています
ですよね
そのはずです
ですが警察官職務執行法が70年近くも
変わっていないと先ほどお話ししたように
法律や制度のレベルで多様化に適用してい
ない部分がいろんな場面で表面化してきて
います
なので次は組織や仕組みが取り組めること
を考えてみました
一つ目は米シャルプロファイリングを含む
人種差別前半を明確に禁止とする法律が
必要だと思います
差別問題はこうダメだダメだと訴える一方
的な働きかけではなかなか改善するのは
難しくて法律でルールとして明確に禁止
する動きと必ずセットであるべきだと言わ
れています
二つ目は特権がはの神ピン式の向上です
警察なども組織の中ではちょっとどのよう
な g 県教育が行われているのが具体的
にはわからないんですが今の時代に合った
ものにアップデートされる必要があると
思います
警察には大きな権力がありますだからこそ
その権力によって不利益を被る可能性の
ある人々のことを最大限配慮する必要が
あると思うんです
3つ目
納得できるエビデンスのページ警察はこれ
までレイシャルプロファイリングが認めず
操作に問題はなかったとしていますであれ
ばその根拠や職務質問での検挙数における
デモグラフィックをこの際開示して
いただいてもいいんじゃないかなっていう
ふうに思いました
最後になりますが私自身の話を少しだけ
私はブラックカルチャーに大きな影響を
受けて今の自分が作られたと思っています
なので
ブラック lives パターン動画
part 世界中に広がった時に私も今
ここで彼らをサポートすることで恩返しし
なきゃいけないと思ってジャパン4
ブラック lives を立ち上げました
このコミュニティで活動していると今まで
自分が気にも留めなかったあらゆる世の中
の二病脳が突然見えたり p なってくる
ようになりました
すでに活動を長くやってらっしゃる方々に
とってはもしかしたら聞き飽きたセリフか
もしれませんが私はすべての社会問題は
つながっているんだなあっていうのをこの
時に初めて実感しました
ほとんどの人が何かしらの属性で不平等さ
を感じていたり理不尽な現実に直面した
経験があるんじゃないかなと私は思ってい
ます
その時の自分の気持ちを忘れずにその
気持ちを持って他者に共感したりサポート
して改善していっている世の中になると
世界はもう少しだけ生きやすくなるはずだ
と信じています
以上で私の話は終わりになります
ありがとうございました